So there are a whole bunch of different interesting
Senate races to follow. We've been following
many of them. And one of them is horrible,
horrible. Senator Lindsey Graham, a Republican
from South Carolina. Lindsey has been in the
Senate since 2003. He won in 2002, entered
the Senate in January of 2003. He's up for
reelection. He has a solid challenger in Democrat
Jamie Harrison. Now, the latest ad from Lindsey
Graham's campaign has taken Jamie Harrison's
skin, Harrison's black and darkened it, which
is something we've seen Republicans do it
all. It never gets light somehow. It's every
time we see one of these things where a black
candidate or politician has their skin tone
modified in an ad. It's never lighter. It's
always darker. And indeed, that's what happened
here. This sometimes happened to Barack Obama.
By the way, you might remember. So in this
ad, which we're showing our video audience
a real picture of Jamie Harrison on the left,
the altered picture on the right.
The ad looks to tie Jamie Harrison to comedian
Kathy Griffin. I guess it's bad if Kathy Griffin
supports you in South Carolina, maybe, I don't
know, among Republican circles. But the most
notable thing is the digital alteration of
Harrison skin tone. The Graham campaign says,
you know, this wasn't actually about making
Harrison look more black. It was just we we
used an effect on the ad. We use the same
effect on Lindsey Graham's face in another
ad. I don't know exactly where. And this is
a total nonstory, they say.
Meanwhile, in another totally coincidental
accident, just a mistake, someone made a Republican
senator published an ad where his Jewish opponent's
nose was enlarged.
Georgia Republic. I had it sounds insane.
I know. Georgia Republican Senator David Perdue
has an opponent. His opponent is 33 year old
John USCIRF also happens to be Jewish. A classic
anti-Semitic trope is the big nose door, hook
nosed Jew. The Perdue campaign published an
ad to Facebook where John Ossify knows it.
Can you believe this was digitally enlarged?
And by the way, Dunn, not super professionally
ossify nose is enlarged, but it also just
looks weird. And adding to this. The ad includes
a picture of Senator Chuck Schumer, who also
happens to be Jewish, but is a senator from
New York, has nothing to do with that race.
And it includes the tagline Democrats are
trying to buy. Georgia, of course, playing
up anti-Semitic tropes about Jews and money
with the big nose and everything. The Perdue
campaign was confronted about this. They said,
oh, yeah, that modification. They're calling
the enhanced nose size a modification. The
modification was made without their authorization
because of an error that a vendor they work
with made.
So I guess blaming it on whoever they hired
to make the ad. Now, is it believable at all
that a vendor would do this?
And even like without the nose enlargement,
that's only slightly better. They're still
including Chuck Schumer for some reason and
talking about Democrats buying stuff, both
of the Democrats pictured happened to be Jewish.
It's very difficult to imagine that this is
an accident, but I guess that's the way they're
playing it now as a preempt, because there
are going to be you know, every time we talk
about this, people write in. They say, David,
Republicans aren't anti-Semitic. It's the
Republicans that support Israel, whether while
Democrats don't or support Israel to a lesser
degree. I I don't know if these are bad faith
actors or they're just ignorant. Republicans
love Israel because they believe Israel needs
to be in Jewish hands for Jesus to return.
OK, there is a huge evangelical Christian
movement that loves Israel, not because they
understand and care about or whatever. Thousands
of years of Jewish oppression.
It's because they think it'll bring Jesus
back. They don't actually care about Jews
as people, certainly not American Jews who
overwhelmingly vote for Democrats. And remember,
Israel and American Jews are to come. Cleanly
separate and different things, Republicans
care about the land of Israel for bogus religious
reasons, sometimes for political reasons.
It's not about fighting anti-Semitism or anything
like it. It's truly horrifying that this is
what we're dealing with right now and all
of these people need to be removed. It's not
looking great. For David, for. For Orsa. John
USCIRF running against David Perdue. The polling
is not great. The polling is not fantastic
for Jamie Harrison against Lindsey Graham
in South Carolina. But let's remove at least
some of these people in November. I hope that
we will. And some Republicans are going down.
I just don't know whether it's these two.
But fight every race, do everything we can.